pro russische demos in deutschen städten
am wochenende zum beispiel in hannover
auch
vergangene woche die welt erfährt gerade
von butscher treffen sich russland fans
diesmal mitten in berlin hunderte autos
fahren mit russischen flaggen quer durch
die stadt während sich die lage in der
ukraine weiter zuspitzt für viele hier
ist putin nicht das problem sondern die
lösung ja du musst du ich denke unser
präsident oder sagen wir präsident putin
hat die richtige entscheidung getroffen
russland hat niemand nur angegriffen
russland rettete erneut die welt vor dem
faschismus in der ukraine ist schon seit
acht jahren krieg nur hat man früher
nicht so viel darüber gehört
putin als befreier nicht als krieg seien
diese botschaft verbreitet auch thomas
rücker er berichtet vom russischen
militär eskortiert aus der ukraine
übergibt dem russischen fernsehen
interviews bezeichnet sich als den
einzig verbliebenen kritischen reporter
ich betreibe vor allem seit dem verbot
von russia today und sputnik in
deutschland eigentlich das letzte portal
mit einem anderen standpunkt
alina lipp verbreitet wie ihr kollege
röper die russische version des krieges
in deutschland etwa auf telegramm
lips kanal erreicht mehr als 100.000
abonnenten
dort zeigt sie russische soldaten vor
einem mit z markierten lkw beim
verteilen von humanitärer hilfe
was nicht zu sehen ist von der
russischen armee zerbombte häuser
getötete zivilisten
massengräber
für die gräueltaten wie in butter werden
ukrainer selbst verantwortlich gemacht
röber schreibt auf seinem portal in
butter habe es zitat kein massaker der
russischen armee gegeben
diese propaganda ist
sehr wirksam und sehr gefährlich sie
berichten auf deutsch aus russland und
sie behauptet dass sie russland besser
verstehen als etablierte
durch journalisten
europa und lip treten immer wieder im
russischen staatsfernsehen auf die nähe
zur russischen regierung zeigt dieses
bild lebt lässt sich mit maria
scharapowa ablichten
2021 die sprecherin des russischen
außenministeriums trifft lipp auch am 16
märz 2022 bereits mitten im krieg wieder
dabei stets sache rover seit
kriegsbeginn auf der eu sanktionsliste
röber und lip erreichen ein publikum das
deutschen medien misstraut und bei
deutschen politikern verschwörung
wittert in der pandemie hatte röper
damit schon einmal erfolg in zeit corona
hieß sein buch im mai kommt eines über
putin auf den markt
die prozent ist wirklich einen
bestimmten bevölkerungsgruppen in
deutschlands und
die tatsache dass diese botschaften auch
ungehindert verbreitet werden diese dazu
ist gefährlich dass sich viele aus der
querdenker und verschwörung szene nun
hinter putin stellen erscheint experten
wenig überraschend eine position gegen
den mainstream einzunehmen sei letztlich
typisch in der pandemie und jetzt im
krieg gegen die ukraine